this week conflict zone is in London and
my guest is the former vice president of
Zimbabwe Joyce Maduro in 2014 she was
pushed out by Robert Mugabe since when
she started her own political party and
hopes to be elected president next year
given the appalling human rights record
of the regime she served why should
anyone vote for her now
[Music]
Joyce majora
welcome to confer exam thank you for ten
years you were Robert Mugabe's vice
president yes at a time when your
country was there as a byword for
corruption murder atrocities torture
with a record like that around your neck
why should anyone vote for you now they
know you know that when I was away from
gumming there's a lot that I was doing
with people that they liked because I
was never just in the office but I had
ministries that I was running Social
ministries that took me out to be with
the people you were a willing and senior
member of a regime that perpetrated
grave human rights abuses that's the
fact isn't it it is a fact and still
ugly trace still goes on but in effect
is known that there's a lot that has
been happening and it is happening in
Zimbabwe hence I'm here to make people
see that yes I was there
but I was an individual in a heaven in
your voice my president you were number
two you are even acting president on
many occasions and did you hear anybody
killed when I was acting president
people were killed in in their thousands
when you were vice president you were
number two you were chief denier and
chief cheerleader for the regime no you
were complicit in everything team still
I used to interviewing people and part
you know putting words in the mouth
that's not true that I was cheering in
2008 I went to Mandar win' and it's on
record you can dig up in the archives
where I asked the people who sent them
to kill you may not know we did nothing
to stop it
that's why nothing to stop it
I wasn't
executive mighty they are ex-president
number two not an executive vice
president
they are executive orders that are
carried out which nobody can stop when
the EU banned you from coming in 2011 it
said you engage in activities that
seriously undermine democracy respect
for human rights and rule of law so they
knew what you were doing with them but
now they have done it the other way
knowing exactly that others yes they
were in the demonstration but without
full knowledge of what was happening
that's why I'm no longer on those
sanctions Joyce majora either you did
know what was going on oh you should
have known had you should have known
what was going on under your nose in
your own future you don't know
everything in life you can hear and with
social media and the reportage that goes
on some of it
you cannot say yes but some of it when
somebody comes out and said I did it yes
you'll be done in a position to talk
about this is this is just an excuse
isn't it because the whole world knew
what was going on in Zimbabwe they knew
about the atrocities which you never
spoke about you never blow keenly about
did you what the world knows already of
what is happening what happened in
Zimbabwe and this is the reason why I am
now able to visit even those people and
talk to them you claim to have know
nothing about the matter be leyland
killings in the early 80s where some
20,000 people were killed massacred by
army units working for your president
you knew nothing about this despite the
fact that your late husband was a senior
Army officer you knew nothing alone have
had already that the 50 brigade was not
part of the army that's commonly you
heard no room
you knew nothing you saw not us do you
test Joyce do you know if in time for
the banditry so-called mandatory I was
even visiting Matabeleland being
minister of Community Development and I
do saw nothing I heard nothing
seeing nothing I didn't see but hearing
yes I was hearing and you did nothing
about it
but what powers would you have vice
president I was I spoken I was in vice
president in NATO I was in vice
president of 1982 I was Minister of
women Affairs and Community Development
and yes I was visiting multiple island
and no warden week-out told you to the
communities about how they can improve
themselves tres Maggiore you went on
denying knowledge for years and years
didn't you in 2011 according to Africa
confidential you told business leaders
that the zanu-pf leadership and the
president were completely unaware of all
the killings and violence committed in
the party's name that's what you said in
2011 that wasn't true that's that's what
he according what the paper said but he
had you so what Mugabe said that it was
a time of madness the world knows that
that more battling selves is it a time
of madness that sees the choice of words
that is choice of what you eat but right
now that way that you right you right
now I am in the Matabele and twice a
month discussing with the seniors in
more in multiple and that you know what
by association yes but this is the
reason why I am coming to face you and
say do we want to live in the past or we
should now start to look forward and we
have an agreement already with the
seniors with the cheeves
in Matabeleland because they know if I
was perfectly and pretending that you
didn't know about all know you're not
oxygenating play I did know
over the decade when you were how to
pretend I actually told them the truth
that you know what by association giving
orders coming from an executive you
can't expect any ordinary Minister to
know that this you never read a paper
you never listened to a foreigner a news
organization you read for a radio
station you read a paper you hear the
radio stations and you expected the
executive to stop that because they not
exactly
and as vice president usually he has no
responsibility whatsoever to step in to
tell the world what was what yeah you
senior vice president I was in vice
president in 1980 - no but - 99004 the
atrocities were still going on weren't
they
but didn't you hear me say I spoke about
it though the voice might have been stop
it I don't know nothing wouldn't stop it
I couldn't you could have gone on
television and radio and talked about
what was happening instead you kept
denying you kept trying to pretend that
nothing was fine and one is seated I
think that's why you think when you are
pushing things that are not true you
want the world to hear Joyce would you
have a fire here are the left me tell
you another fact I have not been the
vice president in 1982 I was the vice
president from 19 2004 and when the
atrocities happened in Jewish a close to
my home I went today in that questioned
who had given the orders and nobody gave
me the answers go to 2009 choice majeure
in 2009 when Amnesty International's
president came to Zimbabwe you remember
that and talked about the impunity
enjoyed by human rights abuses in your
country you brushed her aside you said
the people of Zimbabwe have got over
their differences and have no time to
waste fighting each other as they are
too busy rebuilding their country which
of course at that time in 2009 was
nonsense wasn't it because the human
rights abuses were
continuing in 2009 but today even it
might sound so even now when is can you
answer that question why why you brush
the way I didn't know that's that's all
that's your opinion that's what you said
it's your opinion that I pressed it you
say people of Zimbabwe I'm not over
there do you see I hadn't I was not
responsible for defense ministries I was
responsible for me in Social ministries
you worst and denier for the regime
weren't you you denied in public that
these human rights abuses were have you
not heard that
Joyce Moyer addressed in the questioning
why certain things that came to my ears
were happening without the knowledge of
us some of us you said June 27th 2009
you expressed frustration with the lack
of international aid and you again
pretended in public that there were
hardly any human rights problems in your
country you said yes we still have those
isolated cases of violence but mind you
some of them are very criminal so you
played it down you whitewashed it
isolated violence cases that went away
violent cases that I was talking about
the very some violent cases that you are
saying I did not talk about you know
what the State Department US State
Department said for that year when you
just talked about isolated cases about
do you know what they said about what
was going on in your country they said
security for and this is 2009 when you
were vice president they said security
forces the police and zanu-pf dominated
elements of the government continued to
engage in the pervasive and systematic
abuse of human rights trumped-up charges
arbitrary arrests intimidation I'm very
happy and talking about that because
you're talking about trumped-up charges
and those are either the courts or the
security forces which I have never been
in charge and you just said a few
isolated cases of violence
this was full-scale abuse of human
rights taking place in two annuals
nestled in your
vice-president if somebody's cased for
few for a choice of a word that I agree
but when somebody supposed to have been
involved in cases of violence that is a
serious accusation which I'll not accept
choice majeure why didn't you speak out
about the election violence in 2008 the
extreme election violence that have been
perpetrated by your party's thugs in
fact we can dig it up in their archives
that though those were the violent cases
that I spoke about which I've already
spoken to you about you talked about 80
but what we had we had three months
between March 29 and the vote runoff in
June 27 2008 during which time militias
under the instructions of 200 military
officers battered the opposition the MDC
party almost to the point of destruction
so by Election Day more than 80
opposition supporters were dead hundreds
were missing thousands were injured and
hundreds of thousands were homeless
according to the Washington Post yet did
you mention that we are talking to the
period when South Africa did send even
their teams to Zimbabwe and they are
talking to the period when I personally
was questioning why such things were
taking place you may have a question why
they were taking there you did nothing
to stop them but stopping is when you
know exactly we is doing that but when
you are asking so that you are made to
understand what's going on you don't you
have to ask just what is it have taken
to make you go public and tell the world
what you were seeing one of the worst
incidents took place in May the fifth
that year in the farming village of
China nor what is next her Ari yes
according to the Washington Post
innocent endemic order according to the
Washington Post account women were
stripped and beaten so viciously that
whole sections of flesh fell away from
their buttocks many had to lie facedown
in hospital beds during weeks of
recovery men's genitals became targets
the official post
mortem report on Challinor opposition
activist Alec cherry Surrey listed
crushed genitals among the cause of
death this is what your party was doing
while you were vice-president and they
might be my reaction my party is NPP it
maybe not but you were sorry PS yes
because you well this was going not in
charge when you a junior person and you
are in a position to ask why such things
are happening you I think that the world
should have been able to understand that
there were learn voices that we're
trying to you have no shame do you
for what took place no we may need to
hide ripped and beaten so viciously that
flesh it all away from their body hair
you have motion it hates for a person
who is a Christian like myself you have
no shame no regret no humanity over this
I regret a lot that's why I have this
straight face when I went to
Matabeleland when I'm talking about what
would ever happen to people when some of
us don't know the ones that will have
given orders for such things to take
place you were quoted last year in the
New York Times as saying you were sorry
about the Zano PFC use of violence
claiming you were always uncomfortable
with it and wished you had said more
against it
yes but just just a little bit
uncomfortable with brutality on that
scale where Peter people were beaten
women were beaten so that the flesh fell
away from that buttocks in that made you
just a little bit uncomfortable did it
as a Christian politician team choice of
words to use how you feel it may be best
known and understood by those who are
good at that language but when you are
talking to somebody who should
understand who you are and where you are
coming from I think that was the best
for that time how I felt
why don't we go for justice for those
people for those victims that's why I
mean a matter bitterly why don't you
call for
justice why don't you ask in my power to
prosecute the people my party we have a
department where CP pancamo is no
leading where we would want peace truth
and reconciliation disgusting you wanna
take the easy way out
no not the easy way you know they sleep
awakening and killed during the 2008
violence deserve to be in court is the
beginning I don't I don't go through all
those because I'm not the chief of
justice I'm not the executive president
but as an opposition party I think I'm
trying to do things that will show that
we are trying to work out solutions
you're proud of being Mugabe
vice-president weren't you because I was
made vice president pictured holding his
hand when you met him in 2012 at the
airport when he came back from from
Singapore you even said you were like
his political daughter what do you do
when you have senior people who are
running the country well how do you if
you have a duty of care as vice
president to the citizens of Zimbabwe
you exercise that duty of care but you
spectacularly failed to do that didn't
you you are talking of things that even
happened during the inclusive government
you can also ask them what they do yes
because this is where I'm sure you
should be able to understand the type of
a person who is running the country who
ran the country who had the executive
powers at least one of your elections
your personal elections was rigged it
wasn't it in 2008 the US Embassy in
Harare passed on details thanks to
WikiLeaks we know this past on details
about how one of your elections appeared
to show severe irregularities you were
running for the mount
Darwin West constituency in 2008 yes and
you scored us what they called a
suspiciously high eighty three point two
percent of the votes it was
vicious because the US embassy team in
the area before the election found what
it called substantial anti Maduro
sentiment and yet you one with 83.2% I
have no opposition of any magnitude in
mondo in I remember very well it should
be the election where the opposition
candidate passed on immediately after
that and mind you we were related and we
used to go to address meetings though
not together but he used to go did your
party rigged this election for no no no
when you when you are talking about
rigging which everybody else should they
have known it means maybe I was busy
stashing ballot you know papers and you
personally but your part no it's not
everything that an individual does
inmate in mexico blicket there are
things that happen and you don't you
know once again York leading ignorance
is an excuse I can't say I know it's
wrong to say I know when you win you I'm
not sure just material if you're so
ignorant about what happens as
environment why do you say you can tell
you what you might call a rigging which
I also can vouch for where the crow
heads are asked to take their people
with them to a voting station yes I was
a first part of rigging but the rigging
that you are I anticipate you want me to
to agree to is where somebody you know
that I have spent so much time seeing
people stashing boxes which is not what
I witnessed in my life I did not witness
that but you don't can't say definitely
that it didn't happen in the case of
this election in the case of mondo in
West it never happened it was that way
nobody nobody I can say was even ill
treated during that election Rasheed
Mejia
who is the boss of the hill Zimbabwe
right yes yes since you were one of the
biggest beneficiaries of your party
system of patronage and its widespread
use of political
violence he says you're rewriting
history exaggerating your reformist
credentials we want her to come clean
with her past he said the zanu-pf color
and paint that she is associated with
doesn't go away he's got a point hers
name he has a point because he knows the
world knows have been in zanu-pf since
the days of this trouble I've been in
zanu-pf until 2014 that's no secret
so when such things happened in the name
of zanu-pf it means every one of us in
the country even those letters come
clean tell us what you were involved in
tell us what you did tell us what you
saw that was what you know I never saw I
never was involved but hearing yes but
talking about those practices yes Joyce
Makino knew so little about what was
happening in your country what you saw
you - Zimbabwe your person who didn't
ask wasn't curious didn't know turn the
blind eye what do you say you to
Zimbabwe as a president yes and future
you are failing to hear what I'm saying
that it could have been not failing to
hear the message chapter you are I said
it could have been a drowned voice of
Joyce Maduro but I asked Andy thousand
and nine you one of the richest most
powerful people in Zimbabwe I love that
where courts trying to sell gold in
Europe and defiance of international
sanctions why three and a half tonnes
let me tell you three and half tonnes is
not a small parcel and if there was
anything to do with that why is it that
there is no court there is no case
there's no court for hundreds of
thousands of people who deserve to be
under the court because some of these
things I can say some of these things
are here say they are mentioned and you
try and say to people why don't you take
me to court where am i involved I'm in
Harare that world is somewhere else how
do I know you were using your daughter
Nyasha delcampo as a go quiet it's that
he has notices this is why is it that
is no no quad case about yet why why has
it I'm asking because your courts are
hardly independent uh no no was it found
in the moats are hardly independent by
the way was that world found in Zimbabwe
too was that volume was canceled and you
according to the company you dealt with
scientific master yeah you you were
angry enough to call them directly and
demand that they reinstate no no no no
no no no I wasn't angry I've never been
in mining I've never been a business
person until my husband passed on and um
no for me that's all
you are farming if you are you are
farming Alamein farm which was illegally
seized by your husband from a white
farmer you promised compensation him but
you haven't paid him why not I am
discussing with guy and he knows exactly
what route we're taking so when are you
gonna pay him I don't have to tell you
I've got to tell guy a high court in
Harare awarded him damages in 2015 of
more than a million pounds including
revenue from his tobacco crop but I'm
simply asking why you're delaying
payment it's because I've we have
discussions that are going on but you
know there's a bubble oh and I told lie
he knows exactly the approach that we
are going to take and we did not agree
to make it a public thing but that he
should understand that is national
people proposed party we have that
agreement and the policy that we respect
property rights and we want him to see
that it's not something that we're going
to make is a you know a guinea you know
something that we can just play around
with but that we are serious about the
policies that we have ready agreed to to
be giving how are you going to persuade
people with your new party having
zanu-pf s record of destroying the
economy that you can now manage it under
your government's economic mismanagement
in 2008 we
had 231 million percent inflation
supposed to be something of a
world-record zanu-pf also destroyed the
health service how are you going to
persuade people that you're going to
change this record which you're
associated with our policy in people
first that we are proposing is that
everyone who calls on Zimbabwe or Moscow
he must be free to participate in the
rebuilding of the country and right now
come home to more human rights abuse no
no no no no not under my lead
no not under my leadership that will not
happen
Joyce majora thanks very much how much
well conflict zone thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you